greetings from podcast Ville its
November 12th the church what's
happening now is brought to you by
Stan's socks listen let me ask you
something remember Christmas morning my
socks were one of the worst things you
could get times have changed
that four pack of white gym socks from
your Aunt Susan that ain't happenin
anymore
Stan stocks are here to rock your
Christmas morning incredible design and
comfort listen you guys know I'm on my
feet a lot and whenever I fly I use
Stan's socks like I had to go to Detroit
this weekend you know you're gonna be
doing some [ __ ] walking so if you're
gonna be some walking you might have
some comfortable shoes and even better
some comfortable socks Stan
socks are incredibly comfortable now
here it is right now just for the church
family Stan's as a great offer go to
Stan stop calm slash Church and you'll
get a free pair of socks with any
purchase that stanch grab a pen sta NCE
comm slash Church to get your free pair
of socks because if they're not Stan's
they're not socks the church what's
happening now is also brought to you by
my bookie dot AG we're in the middle of
football season New England had the
weekend off this is your [ __ ] chance
to make some money right Thanksgivings
coming you don't want to show up with a
[ __ ] duck do you you want to show up
with a [ __ ] turkey you like winning
money you like betting sports I'll tell
you what to put your money down my
bookie dot AG why cuz you play you win
you get [ __ ] paid now what
they're doing is they're gonna double
your first deposit today it's Tuesday
get ready Thursday night the party
starts
you got NBA Wednesday use promo code
shirts get a hundred percent bonus on
your initial deposit up to a thousand
dollars we're gonna get that type of
action on a Tuesday morning nowhere so
visit my bookie dot AG today and use
promo code Church when creating your
account to claim your bonus you play you
win you get paid kick this [ __ ]
melee it's going on [ __ ] all right it's
great to just see like I told you when
you walked in it's like watching
somebody grow up in front of your eyes
now you this man you know when I book
the movie I went back and revisited the
series in the beginning and last night
we were talking on the phone it was like
I was watching you just being I remember
the episode when you locked the [ __ ]
window and she couldn't get back in that
second episode maybe three is some
massage I only remember and II need to
cut the machine-gun and you locked the
[ __ ] laundry room so she didn't back
in that might be the pilot factor be the
pilot might be the violent little young
kid that's 12 years old how long were
you acting before that so I start I was
6 years old walking down the street with
my dad and some guy came up to my dad
and said hey your son should do
auditions or you know they didn't know I
was gonna be [ __ ] short and looked
away do but they were like you should be
uh he should be a little model or you
know do whatever so my dad and my mom
but my mom mainly started taking me on
auditions for commercials and [ __ ] like
that and I booked like Pizza Hut at AT&T
like a whole buy BM like I booked all
these commercials and then my
grandmother passed away I broke my arm
all this weird stuff kind of happy to my
life my mom or we she decided I guess
that for me to stop for a few years and
my manager who's still my manager today
which is almost 30 years later this guy
Jeff Mitchell he's [ __ ] amazing
he would call every couple weeks couple
months or whatever and say hey you know
he should get back in he should get back
in and you know we'd be like no no no
and finally when we said yes I went
audition and got Sopranos when you got
the call it was like five out of ten
people who have you know become regulars
and went on to go on the show the first
time you got the call I was in New York
and I got a call one day and they go hey
you drop it off tapes
I had this mediocre agent at that mad at
manager at the time so he goes you got
to drop a tape off and Global
Entertainment somewhere else and this is
show the [ __ ] Sopranos and I'm like
again I'm not an opera singer yeah yeah
so guess what I dropped two tapes off
when I didn't drop the soprano tape whoa
really
the pilot I was in New York like an
April March and they were looking and I
didn't drop it off and well I see
different characters in the show getting
interviewed especially that pilot they
were like you know I was a prawn oh well
I sent us I think Jamie had the same
reaction exactly a couple of people well
how was your when you went and did you
even know you were walking it no well I
mean nobody knew you know it wasn't a
thing yet it was it was just a show on
HBO which at the time was not a good
thing you know you wanted to be [ __ ]
CBS or NBC or one of these things and
but what's funny is everybody who's on
the show thought it was the thing about
singers and everything and then when
they told him no it's not singers it's
about Italian like mafia [ __ ] they were
relieved or with me I was like oh that's
even worse you know I probably got a
better chance of being a [ __ ] sing
because I'm a little Irish kid I got
freckles on my face and every kid in the
audition was like you know slicked back
hair with the [ __ ] leather jacket and
they were all trying to play up the
Italian thing and I remember my mom was
even saying like why did you even send
him on this you know he's he's he didn't
look like everyone else at the [ __ ]
audition and every time I cursed in the
audition David chase laughed every time
in the auditions and in the callback
stand the next one the next one he just
kept laughing and fart I guess that's uh
that's how I got the job I kept I got
David to laugh over and over see what
you were 12 you said I was 12 years old
when you're that old like that that
young that but exactly like is it like a
dream or are you just there and is it
fun like what is it like because when
you're an adult you're like oh this is
my my dream years old sixth grade or
something it's uh yeah you're just kind
of doing it you're just kind of like I
remember doing the pilot and being upset
and James coming over me like what's
your [ __ ] boy why you pouting and I
was it go all my friends are at camp you
know like it was summer camp tunnels
like I want to be with my friends at
camp and not here with a bunch of
[ __ ] 30 year olds you know sitting
around drinking cappuccino or you know
whatever they're doing and like I had a
great time but in my head I'm like man I
want to be what other 12 year
and thirteen-year-olds and I want to be
you know getting my dick wet for the
first time and seeing [ __ ] what's
going on instead of sitting around here
but it was you know thank God obviously
you know because it was the greatest it
was the greatest thing that ever
happened to me how many days that we are
the powerful I don't know it probably
but I would if I had to guess I would
say three weeks - it could be two weeks
could be a month honestly I have no idea
I know towards the end they started
doing some episodes that would take like
six weeks because it just got so like if
we did an episode where the whole family
was there and we're all sitting around
the table and like you know the cousin
that it would take a full day for a
minute and a half scene because there's
eight people you got the wide shot you
got the close-ups you have to do you got
to match the food no you didn't eat with
that hand you wait with the other hand
you didn't know you didn't eat [ __ ]
you weren't eating pasta at that point
you were eating [ __ ] salad you were
doing and you got to match it then when
they finally get your take they go all
right everybody go away for 45 minutes
and we don't go outside you just smoking
cigarettes [ __ ] and laughing and
they would be setting up the lights and
the cameras and everything getting ready
for the next person's close-up and then
the next friend they had to go around
and do eight of those and they do a wide
shot then they do two shots so two
people in each thing and there were
times where we would have one dinner
scene and you'd show up at 6:00 in the
morning go till whatever time at night
and then you'd be showing up the next
day again to eat the same [ __ ] cold
Chinese food for you know 12 hours and
said but it was it never I mean maybe
twice for first for certain reasons did
it ever feel like work to me now so you
shoot the pilot you go home you go back
to your life yeah
total think about it you're 12 you're
looking to get you little balls like
that well yeah well how long do you get
the call well what actually happened was
it didn't happen like that what happened
was I got the pilot and everybody my
family goes he's gonna be famous you're
gonna be on a [ __ ] TV show and you're
gonna be famous this is it this is the
beginning and then we went to shoot the
pilot and people like tony sirico would
be like we [ __ ] you know we do uh you
know five of these every year you know
we'll never see each other again and
then he just [ __ ] shot all my dreams
down I went back [ __ ] twelve years old
back to my family who we were broke like
broke
and telling them yeah you know that what
we thought this was it's not he's a guy
they do these all the time it's a show
for HBO people were Tucker this is a
[ __ ] show for HBO what do you think
it's gonna be a [ __ ] you know a big
deal so I remember going back and
telling my family breaking the news to
them that no this isn't the the big
thing you know and then they called and
said we're gonna do a season and we did
the season and then I remember it never
really hit me honestly until I got a
phone call and they said there's a
billboard with you on it in Times Square
and we [ __ ] my family got in the car
and we drove into [ __ ] Times Square
we're driving through traffic and we're
looking around and we're looking around
looking and somebody's like there it is
and he look up and my face was on the
[ __ ] billboard in Times Square and I
was like oh [ __ ] I heard the premier
party was at a pizza place in the
village I think there might have been a
job like a small like HBO didn't even
think yeah it was really gonna do
anything you know like they had another
Pizza Paul or something yeah which by
the way for then it was like this is
like I was [ __ ] oh I thought it was
the great on the clutter free pizza
everybody's [ __ ] hey I mean it was
amazing you know I thought it was uh
incredible but HBO I think about the
[ __ ] you know it's just crazy like I
think when I was 16 I cuz we were
talking about I grew up on 92nd Street
and 2nd Avenue in New York and I would
be on a Thursday I'd be in the park with
my friends on a you know 16 years old
like drinking forties smoking blunts
getting into [ __ ] trouble and [ __ ]
and then on Friday I'd be flying in
first class on [ __ ] HBO's dime to LA
to stay in the nicest hotel in [ __ ]
la on Saturday Sunday whatever I'd be on
the red carpet of the [ __ ] awards
there'd be [ __ ] you know Tom Hanks
and this one and people talking in that
and by Monday I'd be back in the [ __ ]
Park drinking a 40 smoke at a blonde and
it was and the crazy thing is is now I
look at it and I go this sounds insane
we're at the time I was like yeah no I
would not I was in LA this weekend yeah
[ __ ] I met Tom Hanks you know if I
can I met all the cast of friends I met
all the yeah we're all sitting together
and having a drink and yeah they were
great you know I can [ __ ] like they
used to be this homeless guy who we paid
a bias [ __ ]
alcohol like la we could get beer but
it's hard to get like hard alcohol and I
remember like I'd be [ __ ] telling the
homeless guy about how I was hanging out
with like Ray Romano the night before
you know and it's just [ __ ] it was I
think about it now and I go that's the
craziest [ __ ] ever but at the time it
was totally normal you know I'd [ __ ]
I'd send HBO back the [ __ ] tuxedo
that I rent that they rented from
wherever for me and then I'd leave my
apartment and I'd go to the park and be
drinking and smoking you know three
hours later just like what my buddies
hanging out it was it wasn't odd to me
at all like I just thought yeah this is
life you know this is what's going on I
feel how many episodes before this
[ __ ] thing just because I didn't I
had no idea I was I'm a comic I'm on the
[ __ ] road and people are asking me
have you asked to show us a problem I'm
like no but [ __ ] I was supposed to read
to that show right you didn't drop the
say oh the first time I had was seen it
was I was in Cleveland and I went back
to the room but like a grandma blow and
it was on the midnight showing cuz they
would always have like a six o'clock in
California nine o'clock in New York and
you could watch it again that night
right and it was like maybe Episode five
like what the [ __ ] is this
and I was coked up so I really couldn't
absorb you know my feel didn't but I
knew I gotta watch this [ __ ] again yeah
and from there on I started watching and
it was by yeah by like the eighth
episode right once that was it you guys
were off in the [ __ ] life yeah I had
changed
honestly I don't remember ever not being
huge from the day I saw that billboard
until you know now if I go to a mall in
Jersey it's [ __ ] they go nuts you
know it's still crazy but out when I'm
living my normal life it's knife ink
there's something about when I do with
my [ __ ] facial hair or the way I
shave or don't shave sometimes or my
hair that there's some days where it's
like people I see people staring at me
and pointing at me and coming up to me
and ask me and then there's some days
where nobody [ __ ] you know you go a
full day and nobody even looks at you
nobody
it's great but that yeah there was
because you think about it right eight
episodes in would be two months so to
look back and try and remember like a
two month period where it wasn't big but
from what I remember as soon as the
[ __ ] pilot when it was just it was
fireworks it was crazy
everybody everybody loved it you know as
I was telling David no you know he's not
fun Jovi you got proof Springsteen you
know you got Queen Latifah you got
[ __ ] Naughty by Nature
I come out here in 1997 I signed with an
agent and she goes I need a Bible and I
wrote from New Jersey this is Bruce
Springsteen is always right 97 yeah yeah
booth Springs standing up on Joe we've
got all these [ __ ] people New Jersey
and I'll never forget her calling me and
saying listen I'm changing that Jersey
to New York didn't you say you went to
grammar school in New York and I go yeah
she does I want you to change it to
Hell's Kitchen or something because it's
not cool to be from Jersey she's just
not if people really don't I told David
that I go once this show it everything
changed now you could put that you were
from Jersey yeah people like oh [ __ ]
like it was that much of an impact like
it was that much of an impact and after
that it was often the [ __ ] run it
yeah is it bigger than it is in New York
I mean it's it's the [ __ ] it
represents it's the Bible in New Jersey
everybody yeah what it hook line and
sinker because that's your life in New
Jersey Wow like I can't you can't I
can't go into a deli in Jersey and get
back in the car without somebody knowing
we're like in New York I could you know
we're but you know what's funny too is
like a lot of people come up to me in
New York and they're like did we go to
school together or did we and I'm like
you're [ __ ] 58 like what did we go to
school thing you know what I mean like
people always say they don't know where
they know you know people are like did
you uh were you a tree on the [ __ ]
softball team and that's and I'm like no
and I don't tell them you know why they
[ __ ] know me but I just and they look
and they go oh man my
you know I got a I got somebody on my
team look just like you know they can't
recall where they know me from but in
Jersey and they don't they don't look at
me like where do I know you from in
Jersey you know the second they see you
because I think there's a lot of people
in places where they go oh I did watch
Sopranos ten years ago where anybody who
likes a promise lives in Jersey has not
gone ten years without watching Soprano
no they [ __ ] it's like it was you know
it was they're like oh it's [ __ ] you
know - I watched I rewatched the whole
thing just two months ago you know and
they [ __ ] that's crepe man they they
love it it's great it's crazy to say
that my career started because of the
soprano because before the Sopranos I
had with the pilot for CBS as a Puerto
Rican Martin and the Bronx was called
Bronx County and I booked bass ketball I
was a ref yeah yeah and then you know I
was going out for Big Time audition I
didn't have the chops but then I wanted
from MADtv for the soprano sketch right
the first time they did it and that blue
[ __ ] yeah
why Will Sasso was a great tony soprano
yeah we had a great time woman then we
were gonna do it again
you know the Sopranos kinda stopped this
really I guess Jamie Lynn was gonna host
oh wow they were gonna let Jamie do a
sketch list but I guess the surprise I
was like aha she could hold all but she
ain't doing no [ __ ] sketch so we
canceled the sketch but after the sketch
you have to remember that mob culture
just blew up
yeah our shalls' you know I shot maybe
for commercials a year and I would walk
in and book the thing I know what I
walked in I was booking and think as I
looked just like was he yeah you know
I've looked just like Pennzoil [ __ ]
Sears had a mafia garage commercial I
did a battery commercial for [ __ ]
somebody where would digging the body up
and you left the lights on to dig at
night right we want to start the car and
the car didn't start and they're like if
you that use this battery these mobs I
shot yeah 20 Nationals that we'd shoot
get paid for and then they go not
italian-american Foundation Rhea made
them pull it but light I did one with
what's-his-name at the end they ran over
his head the crank Vincent Frank Vincent
yeah we got taken off
I think his lasted the most on
everybody's like four was did different
mafia commercials it was amazing the
amount of mob action that was in this
town yeah I did a movie you got nothing
it was all mob stuff that just short
films that paid they would pay me you
know they had no budget they would pay
me because I look like Vincent Pastore
yeah of course it was [ __ ] crazy and
then I went to New York I was doing the
New York Comedy Festival and georgeann's
persistant was in the audience
and she came up to me and she goes are
you busy tomorrow you have to meet this
lady she's gonna want to see for sure
and I went outside I was supposed to go
to Buffalo she walked up to me Georgine
walking me she goes can you believe a a
business card upstairs because we're
looking for guys like you're like mom
you're 11 o'clock and we started talking
I read for Gigi I read fir she ripped
this part I read for the cop who's
opening up a pizza place now the federal
cop that used to Oh him I just bumped
into him he's opening up a pizza place
right here in Brooklyn Oh I am back to
Brooklyn I read for that role and David
chases know was keep sending me
everything that you do so then when push
got killed off The Sopranos he was gonna
do a show called the mezzos about
two-game obstinacy
Nancy was developing it maybe si got
cold feet and got rid of the project
they resold it to Fox I did the short
film and then I sent that to Georgia and
she called me in for [ __ ] brother who
was supposed to have four episodes right
but they sent decides to the Comedy
Store well I was doing spider-man - I
was at Sony so in those days you got
yeah you had to be home to turn the
[ __ ] fax fax machine yeah so I went
to the store got the side and the girl
spoke to Schirripa and I think she
remembered my mistake
said my friends are auditioning for this
thing because da Moreira and they called
it like a confidentiality agreement
really so we got [ __ ] snapped get out
of here yeah that you know what's funny
is like I hear first of all I think a
reason why like I don't have social
media I don't do any of the [ __ ] rude
Twitter Instagram Facebook I got nothing
and like I think about it now and I
think about how I like the you know like
I see these shows like stranger things
on Netflix or whatever show and it's
like we're here now look we're eating
them [ __ ] this is what we read this
is what we're doing here's where we're
standing oh look here's dove it and I
think the reason I one of the reasons
one of the many why Sopranos was so good
as there was none of that no you never
saw us sitting around [ __ ] smoking
cigarettes laughing in our pajamas
because that's what we would do you know
they would say you got a [ __ ] hour or
when we would do read-throughs we would
sit around it there were no pictures of
us anywhere if you weren't watching me
is [ __ ] AJ and and and Jim is Tony
and everybody like you know she to
people she was Carmela
she wasn't putting up Instagram videos
every five minutes going oh we're in the
kitchen now or getting ready to shoot
this scene and I think that it just
takes away from the intensity of like
how but like I think people watch the
show especially in New York New Jersey
and they were like no that's Carmela
that's Toni that's not right now today I
think it's like people know so much more
about the [ __ ] celebrities and then
all here's all not the I'm having lunch
with [ __ ] Jake and you know and we're
here and then and it's just I think
there's like and I think that's why now
everything is shifting to [ __ ]
podcasts and actually knowing how people
are instead of these I just think like
the intensity of that like I remember
somebody coming up to me once and asked
him if Tony hit me and I was like what
do you mean
and they're like what does he as he ever
like giving you a real beating I go you
you watch the show whatever is whatever
he said he doesn't hit me when the
cameras aren't on like what are you
talking about and they just like they
couldn't even understand what I was
trying to say like they were just so
[ __ ]
caught up in like they saw me in the
street and they wanted to know if Tony
like beat me and I was like it's
whatever whatever you see like I don't
even know how they answered this guy
asking me this question you know what I
mean
where now it's like they would see us
[ __ ] on Instagram every day you know
hugging each other and laughing and this
and they would never ask that question
cuz they would know you know they would
be like oh yeah I saw you and Tony went
to go get [ __ ] you know the chicken
fingers the other day and that they
would they would never ask something
like that no were you going to school
when you shut the pilot and then with
you you were gonna grammar school
obviously yeah so I was going I went to
school up until about maybe one or two
seasons in and then I was working so
much that I would show up to school and
I wouldn't know what the [ __ ] they were
talking about so then I just kind of
stopped going and I leaned more towards
the [ __ ] kids who were in the park
drinking and smoking and that kind of
thing and then I ended up stopped going
to school and HBO got me a homeschool
tutor for me to finish out and get a
high school diploma so I was just every
I would go to school what I started
doing was I was so they let's say I
would work Monday Tuesday Wednesday you
have off I would sleep until 11:00 and
I'd go to school lunch would be at like
11:30
I'd go wait outside of my school for
everybody to come out for lunch and then
I would try and convince people to stay
out and not go back in and hang with me
and go to the park and [ __ ] drink a
40 or smoke or do whatever and then
sometimes I would sometimes I would end
up like having a few beers at lunch be
okay I'll [ __ ] go back I'll go back
in yeah let's go say hi to mr. [ __ ]
whatever and it was just you know a lot
of the times I shouldn't have that I
probably should have been walking back
in there but uh yeah that was probably I
probably gave up on school around like
14 I would say yeah and then no high
school would really accept me because uh
my days absent was so high you know I
had like a my days absent was higher
than my average in school so my average
was like a 56 and my days off so it was
like 58 or some [ __ ] like that I forget
the numbers but so all these schools
would just see that I'd be like no no
and I remember some amazing [ __ ]
school called me after
if it was like Baruch or like one of
these schools and they go listen it was
the head of the school the woman calls
my cell phone and she goes to or should
call my home phone
I guess feels like I was young so she
calls my home phone and she goes I want
to ask you I'll accept you into this
school if you promise me when you're not
working you'll give it your all and
you'll be the best student you could be
in this school and so you don't have to
go to a [ __ ] MLK or whatever school
in New York that you're gonna have to go
to I'll let you in this school but you
have to promise me I go I can't do that
because I was a cop I'll be lying if I
tell you that that's what I'm gonna do I
go I know where I'm at right now I'm not
gonna all of a sudden [ __ ] flip a
switch and beat [ __ ] and she was like oh
thank you for being honest with me and
and then I went to like a pretty shitty
school and I and you know that was
probably ninth grade and I just never
really showed up you know I showed up
every now and then to I don't even know
why honestly you know there were just
some days where I probably wake up and
be like I feel like I want to see
everybody and [ __ ] hanging out there
but I never even like I don't even
remember getting [ __ ] grades or them
to like it was like I wasn't there you
know and it was like there were a few
people in the school who were cool and
kind of understood like you're you know
because Sopranos was [ __ ] huge at
that time you know so they kind of
understood and I just uh yeah after I
would say like I never stepped foot back
in school after probably the age of 15
that's like a that's like season 3
season yeah yeah ish like around there
and then they got me a tutor but then
what happened was somewhere around like
16 17 I really started going out and
partying and then the school just
[ __ ] it kept slipping so like I would
show up to see her at my K even like my
OB a struggle for me to get to my
kitchen table cuz I'd be [ __ ]
hungover I'd be feeling like [ __ ] and by
like the second hour and she's telling
me these questions and this and my head
hurts and I'm just thinking about you
know the [ __ ] girl from last night
and then I'm just like I don't know you
know I mean you were living the life
that it was you're on the best show on
television you know you were shooting
[ __ ] crazy hours
how many months would you shoot it what
it takes a shooter season so I sometimes
it was six but towards the end it was
more like nine I think it started yeah I
started becoming more
and more maybe like a but then we did I
think that I I have such a bad memory
but if for this I think we started doing
like less episodes as the show went on
but they they just became I don't it
just I remember taking so long at the
end it was so and I remember like they
sometimes they would come to us and say
hey listen uh you know you got to you're
not in the next episode you know you got
[ __ ] two weeks off and I remember
people like Edie if she was she had very
little work or wasn't in an episode
would be upset like they would tell me I
had two weeks off I would be trying to
hold in my from [ __ ] you know fist
pumping and [ __ ] you know being all
excited cuz I was like oh [ __ ] I can go
party I could just go [ __ ] hang out
my friends for two weeks and I know I
got this [ __ ] the the greatest show
in the [ __ ] I have the greatest show
to come back to and then I'd be like all
right you know I'll see you guys on the
look call me when you need me and then I
would just don't [ __ ] hang out with
my friends and I get to call like
alright that's you know the script for
Episode four is out you're in it and I
would just [ __ ] go and but like it
never felt like work working with James
and Edie and Jamie and that they were so
[ __ ] good and ever like you you sit
and you watch Edie Falco do a scene and
then you're like I just [ __ ] I'm
getting paid to be here
it gets the craziest and the way that I
grew up like I grew up really poor and
basically I kind of had the thing where
it was like if you do everything right
you'll get your grandfather's job if you
do everything right if you don't [ __ ] up
if you do good in school you could take
his job but she was like the super of a
building I think oh you and then you'll
[ __ ] you know in our neighborhood he
had it he had the [ __ ] great Jack he
had it easy you know he would [ __ ] go
into work at like 6:00 a.m. or whatever
fix [ __ ] in the building and then at
noon he would go to the bar to have like
a sandwich and a beer and then he just
wouldn't go back to work he would just
end up you know drink away if you need
me and I'll be down at the bar he'd be a
block away but things were [ __ ]
cooler back then you know this is like
the late 80s early 90s or a [ __ ] was
just about you and people weren't
watching every movie makers you didn't
have a cellphone they couldn't get to
you so they'd be Co where's Bobby and
they'd be I go he's you know yeah all
right we don't know what's home tomorrow
and then he would [ __ ] but he showed up
every day 6 a.m. fix it because he only
worked
Kawai you know and then he was the super
of our building too so we got to live in
our building rent-free so there was uh
there were a bunch of us living in the
in a one-bedroom and there was no door
on the bedroom so it was just like a
bedroom with the door open the kitchen
in the living room and we were just all
[ __ ] in there so it's like to then
jump to like you said now this you're on
the [ __ ] best show ever that like I
but the show could have stopped at
season three and I would have been the
[ __ ] success story of you know like
it still would have been like oh my god
this the the you know he did the
greatest thing at the fact that I went
on seven seasons and people argue it's
the best show ever and all the shit's
it's it's crazy to think of how it all
turned out when you were shooting this
while you were shooting these what did
you think of David I love David I always
loved David because I mean I looked at
him as he's the reason I'm here you know
what I mean like he's the guy who gave
me this [ __ ] this thing you know
they're like I was fat and yet I could
still get girls because it was like oh
[ __ ] he's on the [ __ ] TV you know
like I just I love David I love the way
he was I always thought he was a [ __ ]
you know who thirteen year old me what
do I know but I always thought he was
just some [ __ ] genius and he was he
was the best he was funny he was always
super nice to me he I remember one time
where like I was 18 years old and we
were shooting a scene and it was me
James Edie and probably Jamie I don't
remember if Jamie was there we were in
the kitchen doing whatever and I just
remember like turning my head and seeing
David walk onto set and he went to go
watch like on the monitor or whatever
and I remember like feeling nervous and
that was the first time I was [ __ ] yeah
that's my that's the boss you know like
that cuz I never I never when we when we
went to go do the pilot there was no
giant celebrity there was nobody who was
saying oh my god can we can you believe
Baba's here can we get pictures with it
we were all sitting in the same [ __ ]
we'd all sit outside laughing
bullshitting there was never nobody was
from California so nobody was you know
you would hear things about people being
like I want a the biggest trailer
I wanted there was none of that we
wouldn't even sometimes we had trailers
on sudden we wouldn't even go
over there we'd be sitting in the
basement of the house that we were
shooting and just [ __ ] laugh and
making fun of each other making fun of
people doing whatever you know we had we
it was always just us sitting around
having the best time when did you stop
going off the reservation when you
booked it when you were 12 booked it
when I was 12 and you were like when did
you stop partying like why did you get
the green light so when I was like 11 or
12 I think I was 12 I first smoked weed
and done New York City yeah I now look
at the New York [ __ ] City you know I
talk about all the time which what makes
kids from New York City different than
anywhere else it's like let's say
[ __ ] Tom lives upstate and he tells
his parents I'm going to Ricky's house
when he goes to Ricky's house he you
know he's gonna see he's gonna see Ricky
he's gonna see Ricky's mom Ricky dad and
that's it he's gonna see three people
when I used to tell my mom hey I'm going
to rex's house I could see 400 people on
my way from here to just going a few
blocks to my friend's place you know so
you have to you have to learn you have
to be always looking at like what what
what the [ __ ] is this person up to what
are they that we're like I remember when
I was like 16 ish I was doing stupid
[ __ ] and got in a little trouble and and
got moved into my dad's out of the city
for a little bit and I remember talking
a 16 year olds upstate and being like
whoa where are you what do you mean your
mom's gonna drive us to the mall like I
don't I can't even that sounds like
[ __ ] I'd rather sit downstairs and
[ __ ] stare at the wall then sit in
the car with your mom while she drives
us to the [ __ ] money you know because
it was like by the time I was 12 it was
like we'd be hanging out in [ __ ]
staircases and smoking weed and drink in
and then so it was around 12 13 14 I was
drinking smoking weed and that kind of
stuff but it was still just fun you know
it was like hey let's go meet over here
and this and then probably like 15 16
became like oh you know somebody would
because we didn't have money to do other
[ __ ] you know and then around 15 16 it
would be like oh somebody said they
could get us [ __ ] ecstasy you know so
we would save up and try and get it but
then I was probably able to I just had a
little more money and everything but
around 17 end of 16 17 I started going
out to clubs in New York and really
partying and just getting whatever the
[ __ ] I wanted for free like people would
just come on
me with a [ __ ] handshake or wit but
it's also around the time where I got
arrested and I was in the paper for
[ __ ] weed and this so people knew you
know so people would come up to me and
just handshake with a [ __ ] bag of
weed and then around 17
it became blow and I started doing blow
and then from 18 to 22 I was doing blow
every [ __ ] time I drank every time
and then I would so I would binge drink
I would drink for three days just doing
blow staying up [ __ ] party and
everything and then I would chill for
three or four days just smoke weed take
[ __ ] painkillers just kind of like
stay in and then at 22 or 20 be 23 I
stopped drinking for a year to stop
doing coke cuz like I couldn't stop
without I'd be like okay I'm not doing
[ __ ] coke anymore and then it would
be three days later we'd be somewhere
with the [ __ ] windows painted black
and we would just be going for [ __ ]
three days party and everything and like
I think that the difference with me was
like I didn't have a job I didn't have
responsibilities I did so it was never
like like I like you know you do those
impression of those people all the time
and it's like that like I would meet
people they big I had the craziest night
with you we were out til 7:00 a a 7:00
a.m. I'm back what do you like I don't
even like you know people think of crazy
night as I'm staying out till 7 a.m. cuz
they have responsibilities they got a
[ __ ] job they gotta this I was 18 I
had my own apartment I would get nine
months off from Sopranos at a time and I
would just go alright I'm gonna go out
and I'm gonna drink in one [ __ ] night
let into nine months it all of a sudden
I'd be getting that call like alright
we're starting up again I'd be Ike oh
[ __ ] I just all I did was [ __ ] do
coke and drink and go party for yeah for
the entire time and then something in me
I don't know what it was I just let's
say I had to work on Wednesday
I wouldn't even drink that Friday before
just in case if I drank that Friday
started [ __ ] doing blow it turn into
Saturday Sunday Monday then I wanted to
sleep for [ __ ] 24 hours and I woke up
and I just I didn't know my lines or I
didn't what it's so like whenever I
would have to work I would stop partying
or drinking or anything for a long time
before you know and then as soon as we
would [ __ ] alright you got two weeks
off or wrap the season that was it and
it was just like you like yours
we never know what's bad you know we
never know we have a problem so it's
like I went from taking three percocets
a day to all of a sudden taken 15 and
it's like it you don't go oh [ __ ] on
Tuesday I took four and now I'm taking
five and then and then it became to the
point where I would have a [ __ ]
percocet on my nightstand because I
would wake up and I would just [ __ ]
feel like [ __ ] and I would take the
Perkis and I didn't even drink water
with him I would just put him in the
back of my teeth and chew him and I
would just [ __ ] lay there and then 15
minutes later I'd be like all right you
know I could [ __ ] get out of bed now
and function and then I would stay home
for three or four days smoking weed
taking percocets taking xanax watching
TV playing online poker doing whatever
and then I would get the call like
hate's we're going out tonight
you know it's Baba's birthday or that
and that would be a Friday Saturday
Sunday just drinking partying but like
I'm so grateful I look back now that
that it all happened because it's the
reason why if I meet some chick today
and I get marry and everything I could
tell her like listen I'm not going
anywhere you're not gonna I'm not gonna
be one of these [ __ ] so all of a
sudden took a [ __ ] business trip to
Vegas with his friends and now he
discovered [ __ ] blow and hookers and
it like I know what worked through it
yeah I know what I want you know I know
what I want in life it's not that cuz
even though I stopped doing blow so I
stopped doing blow when I was about 20
so 23 or 22 whatever so I stopped
drinking for a year so I go back to
drinking I go if I ever do blow again
that's it I'm never drinking again and
about six months into that I found Molly
and I was like alright well it's not
blow and then I would just [ __ ] stay
up for days I just replaced Molly with
blow and I would just stay up for
[ __ ] three days doing Molly non-stop
part and you just you know you you you
just start to be around a lot of people
that you shouldn't be around you know
and a lot and especially with I quit it
goes but you don't even one minute you
know in the next minute its Maximus you
don't even know what the [ __ ] out comes
with [ __ ] pills and yup and you're in
yeah that's what people don't understand
your and how was it wants to show on did
I you know I wasn't sad about you at all
I wasn't saying ready to move on I don't
even think for me there was any sort of
like transition like it was like on
Monday were doing the show David said he
went
doing anymore okay cuz it was like on
one hand I guess I just thought in my
head like well I don't have to work I
don't have to take those times off from
partying anymore you know I don't have
to [ __ ] clear my head for a [ __ ]
three days before I go to work I don't
have to it now it's just hanging out my
friend so my manager when I was like 22
23 was like you got to keep working out
so problems anything and I was like give
me six months or however long I said you
know give me a year I just want to hang
out my friends and I want a [ __ ]
party I want to do nothing and then that
turned into six seven years of just
[ __ ] non-stop partying and like
people would always just talk about like
how do you how do you [ __ ] drink so
much of party so much is like because
then I could go sleep for 20 hours if I
want you know like I don't have [ __ ]
kids with toys banging them in my head
waking me up in the morning I don't have
a wife I don't have any [ __ ]
responsibilities I if I don't feel good
I want to sleep for twenty hours and
then take percocets for three days and I
just had no and I when I went to see
help seek help what he told me was the
reason why I was having that anxiety he
thinks is because I was just like when
you see a [ __ ] piece of like lint
floating in the air he's like that's how
you were you didn't know what was got
you words end and even though you
enjoyed that your body couldn't [ __ ]
handle it your brain couldn't handle it
you couldn't you needed some kind of
anchor you needed that thing that was
gonna stop you and make you clear your
head for three days and go to work and
that you couldn't just be that piece of
whatever floating around what did you
get so booked so when I was 28 my 28th
birthday I went out I took like 35
Molly's and I was [ __ ] out of my mind
like I was just I went to go see a
concert and I was in [ __ ] Madison
Square Garden so I I show it to my
friend's place and I go I'm gonna take
five mollies and we're gonna go to this
[ __ ] concert we're gonna have a good
time so let's say the concerts at 10 I'm
making up times I don't remember time so
let's say the concept tent seven o'clock
I take five Molly's and I'm [ __ ]
drinking tequila and hanging out so now
all of a sudden it's 9:30 and I'm like
you know what it's my birthday and I
kind of had in my head like I'm gonna
chill out after this I'm gonna stay but
I always did you know I always had that
thing of like with perk
I'd be [ __ ] taking percocets every
day for a year and every night I would
get in bed be alright tomorrow we're not
gonna take the [ __ ] percocet so we're
gonna so you know or we're gonna take
three instead of taking [ __ ] twelve
we're gonna we're gonna in the next day
oh just you just fall back into that
routine you forget you know you wake up
you [ __ ] chew one then all of a
sudden an hour later you take another
one then you're [ __ ] popping xanax
and this so we're about to leave for the
the concert and I go you know what I'm
gonna take five more [ __ ] mollies and
just be off my [ __ ] ass at this
concert I go there's nobody gonna be
looking at me it's gonna be [ __ ] dark
I had like sunglasses on and a [ __ ]
you know a scarf and I'm all [ __ ] you
know I'm like we're gonna have a [ __ ]
ball and it was like a DJ so everybody's
gonna be off their [ __ ] ass then
we'll go on party after so I take five
mollies and then I took like a bottle
like this and it was a ginger ale and I
put tequila in it and I cracked five
Molly's in there and I was like in case
I'm in the concert and I feel like it's
going down cuz at the time I wasn't some
guy who ten Molly's [ __ ] you know
ended my life like some dad from [ __ ]
you know the suburbs I was already taken
numbers like that
you know if not a little less but it was
my birthday I was gonna take a little
more so I got this ginger ale full of
tequila and the Molly and I'm walking
into the concert and I'm [ __ ] like my
teeth or [ __ ] chatter and I'm [ __ ]
I'm feeling good but I'm loving I'm with
[ __ ] two of my best friends I'm on
top of the world everything's great but
it's now when I think about it like I
was [ __ ] rocked and I get to the
front of the line and some guy who
looked like a comput he's probably just
a security wray he's like hey and he
sees me and in your head for that once I
can you just go oh it's all over you
know you don't know why he just goes oh
[ __ ] he knows or something then like
anyways you can't bring that in and I
had the [ __ ] ginger ale in my hand
with the tequila and I was so relieved
that he just said you can't bring that
in and not your [ __ ] coming with me
or you're under or whatever I unscrewed
the [ __ ] tequila with the five
Molly's drank that and walked into
Madison Square Garden and I was saw him
on fifteen Molly's in maybe four hours
something like that and I'm in there and
I'm just [ __ ] rocked like I remember
walking through the [ __ ] hallways and
people have on the [ __ ] glowing
[ __ ] lights day and I remember
like getting to our seats and people
were all so [ __ ] up at our seats so
they're like high-five in this and I'm
saying is my birthday so I'm saying to
these people thank you for coming and
they they're looking at me like thank
you for coming thank you for coming to
my birthday like I think somewhere in my
head I thought it was my [ __ ]
birthday party the Madison Square Garden
with [ __ ] two lenita whatever 40,000
people ever and I had a great night that
night we [ __ ] party we stay at the
concert everything's amazing and so
that's a Friday like Saturday Sunday I'm
still up I'm taking Molly every like
hour you know taking a little taking a
little I go to bed I wake up and I
remember like it was probably four days
after that I was supposed to go to a
birthday dinner and I remember being
like I can't get out a bit like I
remember being like just feeling cold
feeling like [ __ ] and off when I was
like I think I might have done it this
time like I might there might be no
coming back from where I'd like I would
[ __ ] hear something in my hallway it
sketched out like I was just super I was
[ __ ] up and I remember saying I gotta
go to the doctor cuz I couldn't eat
anything I would eat out throw up
I'd eat I throw up I was just over and
over so I go to the doctor and he's like
when's the last time you ate a [ __ ]
vegetable and I'm like I'll you got
chicken fried rice they got Peas and in
the [ __ ] chicken fried rice I eat I
eat that he goes you got to stop what
you're doing right now because you got
to stop drinking for a while because you
got to eat some [ __ ] vegetables you
got to try doing some [ __ ] kind of
exercise I hadn't done exercise and I
don't know six seven years like any sort
of and like even like a walking on a
treadmill in my living room because
sometimes I would get fat like I would
gain [ __ ] 20 pounds and I'd get on
the treadmill on incline and watch a
[ __ ] TV show or whatever but like
besides walking I had done nothing for
so long and he's like you gotta do this
you gotta do that so that week I
remember I left his office and I went to
a place that made [ __ ] vegetable
juices and he goes go get it just all
vegetable juice it's like all right I go
I drank that and I felt high like I felt
but because my body had no [ __ ]
nutrients for seven days but also like I
just I felt good like I was like holy
[ __ ] like I could keep this down I'm at
my bike I haven't had vegetables and who
knows how long I feel real good
I went to like the park the next day I
meet up with my friend and he's okay
we're gonna start [ __ ] doing yoga you
should start so I start doing the
[ __ ] yoga and that and I'm still
taking the percocets and the xanax and
everything but I was like I made the
decision then that I was gonna stop
doing Molly and stop drinking and that
was seven years ago
I haven't been drunk since then but I
was at a dinner like four years ago and
somebody gave me a vodka soda by mistake
and I thought it was a soda I just said
club soda I think I thought it was baka
club soda everybody I was with his
partying and when I took a sip of it I
realized there was vodka in it and I
remember people like freaking out and it
was this whole big thing and I became
obsessed with like not liking the fact
that I I was that guy like I like oh no
we don't know what could happen he's
he's he has no control over that he's on
who knows what would happen if he drank
that this so I called up my best friend
sob I'm 34 now I met him in preschool
like 30 years the name was Rex he's the
[ __ ] greatest guy and I go I need you
to comb me to dinner and we're gonna
open a bottle of wine and I'm gonna have
four or five sips of a glass of wine I
just need to know what's gonna have to
live my life differently if four so I
just felt this way like if I drink these
five sips of wine and it leads to a
[ __ ] crazy night of partying and this
and I know I'm never gonna drink again
whatever but I just need I need for
myself to know because I was laying in
bed at night like what if that sip that
I took was too big what if I what if
there was more out what if there was
more vodka in that [ __ ] glass then
then there was what if there was
straight vodka and I took a sip word I
have [ __ ] fallen off so I just I
wanted to know for me and I went to meet
my boy and we had a [ __ ] couple sips
of wine and I that was it it was over I
was like okay now I know I this is I'm
not so weak or you know and and I'm not
trying to say that anybody who can't if
somebody can't do that that they're weak
I just wanted to know am i this week for
around alcohol if I have four sips is it
gonna take over my [ __ ] mind and and
make me do things you know just make me
fall back into that same person I was I
really I couldn't shake that not knowing
thing
and uh yes so it's been seven years and
there were probably have been three
instances where at dinner I took a
couple sips of wine otherwise I haven't
had a single drink I haven't I mean I
haven't been drunk I haven't touched
Molly or coke has been around the state
like Coke was like 23 and I'm 34 so 11
12 years something like that and then
percocets is less percocets is like four
or five years maybe five years xanax
took me a long time to get off xanax is
a [ __ ] [ __ ] for me everything was
easy compared to is it like people talk
about opiates and I guess obviously the
withdrawal from you know something like
heroin is a lot rougher than percocets
but when I had to deal with with the
benzos is like a [ __ ] it's just the
worst night because how long was the
process years you know it was a really
long time because I was taking something
like uh roughly three mil I would take
like a bar and a half everyday maybe
like a little bit more and but it just
became which is not that I in my head I
don't think anything is a lot you know
but I feel like that's not a lot but it
became six years of doing that every day
or seven years or something and so I had
to go see a specialist because I
couldn't shake it I'm like the percocets
I figured out on my own the drink and I
was like I'm just you know I've done
everything when with the benzos
I couldn't even I couldn't figure out
how to even lessen my dose and I'm gonna
tell you what the guy told me obviously
anybody out there don't take my [ __ ]
advice I'm no doctor I'm just telling
you what he told me which was the first
thing you have to do is get yourself on
a schedule cuz your brain when you're
not on xanax it's up and then you take
your xanax and it's here and sometimes
you don't take it for three hours so it
gets that he said you have to get on a
regular thing so if you say two hours
after I wake up I take my first xanax
and I take one every three hours and I
take the exact same amount so let's go
so that was my first step though my
first meeting he goes just start doing
that I go okay no problem next time I
came to see him he's like alright once
you get comfortable with that you think
you're gonna go less and less super slow
over and over so you're gonna go from
taking point five six times a day to
take in you know half of
point to or you however you want to do
it so he gave me for the first time in
my life I had a prescription for [ __ ]
xanax which is crazy like it took me
quitting to get finally get a
prescription I'll just get him on the
street you know and so he goes because
I'm up taking the bar so I'll give you
milligrams so that it's easier for you
to quit because if you have a bar it's
hard to make point to five out of a bar
or point you know three seven whatever
you want to do so he gives me these
point 0.25 so I start taking like one
and a half point two fives every three
hours or whatever it is and then going
to and and then once I got really low on
the milligrams he goes right now starts
pacing it into every four hours instead
of every three hours you're taking it
and then you're gonna only do it three
times identity so um I mean this was
years of a process how did it affect
your sleep uh it wasn't too bad because
I always kept that one at night like
right before bed the the problem became
what really took me a long time to was
the idea of having none right like the
idea of lessening it was something I
really wanted to do so it was kind of it
wasn't too hard it was like okay trying
to quit on my own was [ __ ] insane
like I said to you earlier the feeling
the only way I can describe it is like
if you're trying to quit xanax for me
it's like if your biggest fear is
Heights and somebody takes you skydiving
and right when they open the [ __ ]
door to that plane and they turn to you
and go are you ready and the way that
you feel right they are looking out
however many thousands of feet up that's
how I felt sitting on my couch watching
TV like it was just all day that [ __ ]
rattling fear of it was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
to open my front doors a [ __ ] to get
into the [ __ ] elevator like
everything was just it was [ __ ] it
was torture trying to quit on my own
well what he told me to do made it a lot
easier and then uh my sleep didn't
really get affected until it was time
for to not do any at all so what
happened was this guy told me uh you're
gonna have to eventually not do any and
I just couldn't I couldn't do it like I
was like I can't not take that one in
the middle of the day in that one at
night like I feel like I'm holding on
too tight to it I don't know what to do
so he's go right when you're ready you
know the
same way you did this one you're ready
when you're ready so I had to come out
to LA for a little bit I come out and
this guy was this guy was a specialist
and he charged $300 to go see him and
after I saw him a bunch I was it listen
I can't afford to come see you anymore
so he's what I'll do is I'll charge you
150 to come see me so I'm like okay so
I'm paying the 150 to see him but I'm
also getting the xanax from him so in my
head I'm like well that's I'm saving
this amount of money by not buying the
[ __ ] xanax right so so he tells me I
go I'm going to LA for a while so I come
back from LA however long I was gone and
we have our first meeting and my bill
shows up and it's $300
and I was like oh this guy forgot that
we're on a [ __ ] 150 schedule so I hit
him up I go hey remember it's it's 150
not 300 and he was like oh no well you
didn't see me for a while you were in LA
now that you're back it's it's 300 and I
was like what do you mean we agreed on
150 when were you gonna tell me this
trick and I don't know if it's the
[ __ ] Irish in me if it's the Attic to
me it what the [ __ ] it is but I was like
[ __ ] this I was like I'm not taking that
xanax tonight I don't care if I [ __ ]
feel like I'm falling out of a plane I
don't care if I feel like I'm [ __ ] I
can't sleep for [ __ ] three days I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm never seeing this
dude again and I'm not restarting this
[ __ ] with somebody else and I remember
three days later I'd never touched a
xanax ever again so like I said to you
there's times where like I hurt myself
in the gym and I'm like I'll smoke a
joint at night or take a [ __ ] Hillary
photo fun oh yeah I don't like to say
I'm sober and then somebody sees me and
buying weed at the store or in yeah yeah
my thing was the alcohol too yeah I
could do one drink two drinks and one
when I was twenty once I did three seven
come for now and I'm gonna Irish you you
can rape me yeah yeah I'm telling you
the truth
yeah when I was 20 the first one I could
control the second one I can control but
the third one we're going to Washington
Square Park with combinate valiums for
$10 yeah then we'll go on a 135 pick up
an 8-ball and then we're gonna stop at
181 and pick up some [ __ ] and have 66
Express and wish you'd know where the
George Washington Bridge so for me today
reefer is my teddy bear yeah that is my
right I could look use both in the air
right now and will tell you I don't even
think I get that high anymore right I
got up in the morning and I do you know
8 bunks at [ __ ] 7 well yeah I've seen
the [ __ ] video I know what you're up
yeah my do it to get the appetite yeah
exactly yep if I don't smoke in the
morning I won't be welcome home I know
it's a drag to eat so if I smoke I'll do
a protein shake something yeah just I
don't go out and then get sick while I'm
driving right there's a final need I'll
get sick while I'm driving all right I
don't consider weed at all yeah but look
by the way there's some people who do
and they can't they can't smoke because
they feel like that's exactly Domino
yeah and it's a trigger absolutely I
don't get that for me I needed to keep
me over look they do sober October yeah
yeah and I spoke to Joe about like I'm
gonna be strictly honest with you do you
know when I went off the most in my life
that was told see I'm CUBAN then being
Cuban is almost as bad as being [ __ ]
Irish okay almost this stubbornness
being [ __ ] Irish will be even more
stubborn than you guys if you said to me
Joey I don't like when the do you want
to see the doctor because I think you
should quit with everything yeah that's
one thing when you were on probation
until you couldn't smoke that's what
eats my craw
yeah the rule is the one hour break so
you come to me tomorrow and go look I
must start testing you once a month you
know we're gonna test you for whatever
I'm gonna smoke it's when you say to me
like yes I got up I did smoke too last
night yeah I got up yesterday morning
and whatever [ __ ] Omaha and I didn't
have papers I had the weed but I didn't
smoke and I got home and I got busy and
like like slide nine o'clock ice Lord
yeah and I was happy I got a little
hungry whatever you know but that's my
teddy bear yeah alcohol let me face them
I never liked it I'll drink you can be
social I'll drink it too
Jesus Christ there's nothing worse in
the world withstand I want to cope with
a lime and faking that you drink I
[ __ ] Cuba Libre
okay nothing bothers me more than to
have a [ __ ] you drink it are you
[ __ ] not yeah if you're not drinking
go to home cuz you make yeah it's like
wouldn't get Christopher it's toast
Paulie go through the reward you trying
to jinx me you know if you're not gonna
drink go home do me a favor you know
those people that go to the bar I'm here
the drinking club so he's gone
you bring you're making everybody get
depressed I always I grew up in the 70s
Robert where every TV show if you watch
any TV show from the 70 when you walked
in like person's house they had a cart
oh my heart with two bottles no label
you didn't know what you would drink
it's like let me get a scotch
no they poured and gave it to his Brown
that's it it was brown yeah
rye it could be whatever you drank it
right now we got [ __ ] now people like
well it's got any calories right no the
seventies boom bomb is a heart I wish I
could do that yeah I wish me to re
places every day and just have a drink
we can give it a drink it of tequila
bulb and then not not again like maybe
like it's six have another one maybe go
to a comedy store and I would love on it
you know many times I go to a commie
song I'm like tonight I'm drink it right
get the [ __ ] bar either how long has
it been since you've tasted alcohol
Saturday mate okay yeah I have two shots
of Jagermeister on stage right Friday
night but again doesn't do nothing to me
yeah I had to double yeah yeah and it's
just for me it's like I just went over
my weight watcher points with sugar like
that so I'm gonna blow it was all that
was my world
I love to blow the Kapil the alcohol
combination the pill like Downers
oh yeah yeah I don't like no no way no
speed no what's that [ __ ] all yeah I
took that once I remember I don't even I
just feel like I can't sleep that was it
I didn't I didn't like for me Perkis
like like I said early I loved
[ __ ] percocet I love drinking I loved
in the [ __ ] but probably I mean there's
a chance that Coke is like the thing I
did the most of and like I never even
liked it you know what I mean like I
remember there were times where I'd wake
up next to a girl and see her doing
[ __ ] wake up doing coke and I'm like
oh
my god like what the [ __ ] is but then
you know I would think I was disgusting
and not would be around her and then 10
hours later I'd be like where's that
[ __ ] girl's number
you know like I'd be looking the [ __ ]
gate cuz I would I would be [ __ ] six
drinks in and like I got to a point
where I would drink a bottle of tequila
before I'd go out before I would leave
my apartment so I would I had like those
red [ __ ] plastic cups in my apartment
and I fill it with like I would be sit
on my couch feeling like [ __ ]
and I'd be like alright I'm gonna fill
up [ __ ] cup up with tequila drink it
and then buy somewhere around the second
one when I'm [ __ ] smoking that
cigarette and I'm sorry I put a [ __ ]
song on and I start [ __ ] feeling good
and then I get I had a place in the
shower for my [ __ ] cup of tequila and
I'd be in the [ __ ] shower and then by
somewhere around the [ __ ] fourth one
maybe I'd start hitting people up
alright where are we going what time you
come in the [ __ ] pick me up and I
meet you there and there and by the time
that bought there was a little bit left
in that bottle I was ready to [ __ ] go
out there I've put in a ginger ale
bottle or a water bottle whatever I
would drink it in the cab or in my
friend's car might so like I have
friends who I've been friends with for
10 years who think I'm the most social
like only loved if I could talk to the
[ __ ] wall and this were because they
only saw me outside of my apartment
after drinking a [ __ ] bottle of
tequila you know where other like then I
have other friends who like lived in my
neighborhood who have known me since I
was [ __ ] 6 years old who are like Oh
Rob will sit in his [ __ ] crib first
you know six seven days to wheat like
there's times where he just doesn't come
out where I have friends who friends
that I knew from going out and from
clubs would would if you told them that
I'm that way they would beg you don't
know Rob he's nothing like that because
I wasn't because as soon as you start
drinking I'd wanted I'm I think a lot of
my problem my problem was like being
around people you know and I soon I
would be if I was sober like if you put
me right now so we're standing in a
[ __ ] nightclub I want to blow my
brains out so that's why I would have a
[ __ ] bottle of tequila and there's
nowhere I wanted to be more than the
club because nobody's [ __ ] talking to
you you're just dancing everybody I know
that guy's got Molly that guy's got
[ __ ] blow that and nobody like when
it when it came to percocets and weed
and [ __ ] like that I always had to put
money up to get them where when it came
to [ __ ] coke and Molly the amount of
money if like
if you put the amount that I did
compared to the amount of money that I
spent on it it would be uh nobody would
believe how that's possible because you
just go out to clubs in New York and
everyone's got it we've got everybody's
giving it to you oh hey you want some
[ __ ] mana here's this and then all of
a sudden you're in somebody's apartment
for [ __ ] three days and there's a
[ __ ] plate of just a mound of [ __ ]
that one's coke that one's ketamine that
one's [ __ ] Molly and you're just
[ __ ] hanging girls are coming through
you're laughing you're [ __ ] partying
musics on the neighbors are [ __ ]
complaining banging on the walls and
you're just you're having the time
you've smoked a hundred and forty
cigarettes you dough you're [ __ ] in
the I love what is this chair made out
of you know you're just [ __ ]
everything's it's amazing and then three
days later I'd be the guy who's not
leaving his couch for ten days that if
you told those people that that's how I
was they'd be like nah that's not that's
not Rob he's he always wants to [ __ ]
you know he would be the [ __ ] head of
the the Thanksgiving Day Parade throwing
a [ __ ] baton in the air because
that's how I wasn't I was drinking I
always wanted to [ __ ] party more more
no let's not go to bed let's this where
like when I would be on [ __ ] pills in
my apartment I didn't even want more
than two people in there cuz I start to
get [ __ ] crazy like oh where are they
you know where is he ashen where is he
that you know like that whole thing
where when I was if I had drinks and it
would be like hey you could put that out
on my [ __ ] forehead like you could
[ __ ] throw cigarettes on my floor
like I don't you know you just it's it's
crazy how it how it all [ __ ] works
I was Robert I live today I go to gym
five days a week
I eat super clean more reliable you know
like I used to be like I remember there
were things for my family just not
showing up when you were addicted you
have no well I was adapted I was not I
could tell you I'll be there Friday good
luck right I don't know how I'm gonna
feel or what's gonna happen Thursday
night so there's no I've told me a
thousand times I was duped still doing
coke this podcast would not be intact
because it's just no way you can't
control your life yeah and there's no
you're gonna go and then you know Friday
you'd want to do it and then [ __ ]
Monday you'd hate it you know you'd be I
don't want to [ __ ] be sitting in that
room and they were like you [ __ ] have
it's just do you want to hack today how
do you feel about
you've done I don't enjoy the I hate
[ __ ] reading scripts
I hate auditioning I hate that whole
part of it so it's like when like I
thought for a long time I was passionate
about acting but really I was passionate
about doing Sopranos I loved it I would
like I stopped [ __ ] drink it for it I
stopped doing draw like whatever when
that time would come and it was never
like [ __ ] I gotta stop this guy it was
like no this is how it works like I get
to do that like I loved doing that work
I loved hanging out with those guys I
loved all of it we're now like the idea
of like some agent is gonna send you
[ __ ] four scripts and you're gonna
sit in your apartment [ __ ] read them
and maybe like it works and like I don't
want to do a TV show because I don't
like the what they might tell you you're
doing in a year it my totally
unpredictable where it's like I have all
of these like things I don't you know if
they were like you're gonna be [ __ ]
uh smoking or you're gonna be [ __ ]
you know smoking a cigarette or we want
you to eat this right and I don't want
to be a difficult guy who's like hey
actually I don't eat that anymore
I won't smoke a cigarette I don't want
to be [ __ ] doing this and that so
that's like I love [ __ ] you I love
Joe Rogan I love the [ __ ] Bobby Lee
Tom Segura so that's I moved out here to
start a podcast and hopefully that'll be
that'll be the thing that I'm doing
stuff I gotta be honest with you how the
[ __ ] do you follow us oh it's crazy how
do you go into a CBS show today and
[ __ ] bum [ __ ] jolly director comes up
to you and says for this thing how it's
you worked with the best yep you came
from an environment that was healthy
listen last not ashamed to say this
about two years ago I did two episodes
of a show for Greg Garcia first one was
great I walked in i was the second scene
up when I left the second time I went to
shoot the same show I had the first
scene up and basically the last scene at
10 o'clock at night so you're there from
9:00 in the morning you do your one hour
and then you wait being in that room and
no windows made me crazy I love I love
Greg
after like a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah well I
left there that night I went home a
night I blamed on the anxiety and the no
windows but really what it was it was
like I just don't think I want to do
this anymore
yeah when I got the call for the soprano
movie that put the audition on tape I
didn't think about it again when they
called and made the offer I was thinking
about not taking it like I heard you
talk about Tom pop I had to come in and
say take the [ __ ] tank when I was
there just being after the first day of
watching what David chase was about like
I was trying to improvise yeah if
somebody came over their life at all
yeah and I remember there's all this air
you know that's what it all came to me I
will left it right back to the room
rolled with three joints went outside
smoked one and I think I work today that
I have like four days off for those four
days I just immersed myself with the
episodes just to see his style yeah and
the second day I went in there I was
like now I'm already mentally the David
chase this is something that I've never
seen before
yeah and I've been a comic for years you
know I've worked with some great
directors at that moment he blew
everybody out
once I saw we did that first save my
shot yeah I was like I'm paying
attention to this guy got a [ __ ]
letter from now on if he says sneeze I
will sleep yeah yeah
I didn't eat nothing that movie either
by the way I hate that [ __ ] too
yeah they asked me to smoke a cigar I
think I smoked one of them but once like
right now somebody offered me a a mob
movie a few weeks ago now his life no
let's see what what the thing is is a
lot of what people don't understand this
industry is like if you're putting all
of your [ __ ] aside all the [ __ ] you want
to do or how I really want to be and I
gotta [ __ ] focus on this thing and I
gotta what but you know it's something
that you think is gonna be [ __ ]
incredible it's different than trying to
put your whole [ __ ] life aside
changing the person you are everything
for some show that might be okay and why
you sure
you're like nobody watches this you know
well they come up to you and go excuse
me
well the script he comes up dances hi hi
the word is uh instead of uh yeah does
it really matter he [ __ ] to watch
this [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] between
the and what was great about the
problems with us is you know by seasons
four or five people would be like how
did you prepare to go do it it's like
you walk into the Sopranos kitchen and
you see Jim pacing and sweating and you
see Edie banging her nail you know she
had those fake nails and she'd be
banging them on the [ __ ] counter
that's it you're there you know we're
like we were a [ __ ] some sort of a
family you know as soon as you went back
in it was all the things were there you
there was the place where you sad and
you had your thing and like they never
told us any of that stuff like you got
to say this you got to stay on script
you have to do this but we would see it
when other people would come in you know
so we would hear you know like we would
do something off and nobody would say
anything but then they would make like
one word wrong and somebody come over to
them and then we would find out later
like you you know you're sitting around
having a drink and they go oh yeah they
told me like you know I said this
instead of that or that instead of that
and then you're going man not only am I
getting paid to [ __ ] work on the best
show ever
but I also have some sort of [ __ ]
seniority where these people let like I
could [ __ ] they don't come up to you
and tell you hey you know you [ __ ] it
like of course the director would come
to you and give you directions a
shilling but nobody ever said hey you
put the [ __ ] you said the instead of
end but they would say it to [ __ ]
other people you know and and you and
you see that a lot you see people come
in for three days and they're [ __ ]
shakin and people are all nervous like
oh we heard that that people are real
strict around here and then we would
tell them nah nobody's [ __ ] strict
around here everybody's cool so then
they'd get all loose and people would
come over you know and be like hey you
said the instead of then and they look
at us like I thought you said then we'd
be like hey I don't know you know we
said yeah it's [ __ ] yeah it's not
what did you learn from Jim so much you
know I mean just from the acting that I
learned from watching him you know cuz I
I talked about before we're like I don't
think I was ever a
great actor but I think the actor I was
from Season one until the end I think I
did grow yes you grew dramatically yeah
thank you for matically and I think it
was from James and Edie watching that I
mean it was like I felt like I was
watching the two like greatest actors
I've ever seen all that all the time
like you just show up and you see what
they do and you see why why they do
certain things and how they like you
know like it would be more so like you'd
watch Edie and then she'd [ __ ] come
by and in the scene she would just come
and like rub her nails on my back or
like something like that and it would be
those things where I go oh [ __ ] that's
she was she was there she wasn't what's
the next [ __ ] line or where do I put
this now
she she saw the [ __ ] and look on my face
and felt like she needed to put her
[ __ ] you know nails on my back and
let me know that it's it's great but
really what I learned from him also I
think in LA especially or there's a lot
of like this outward like we support
whatever you know we're we're resupport
your decision to it's standing from the
[ __ ] rooftop and screaming how good
of a person you are what you support and
I remember I don't remember if her Jim
had passed away already or what but I
remember my manager coming out to me and
telling me like you know he calls me and
I'm like for what do you mean he calls
you and he's a keep calls me and he
tells me not to tell you that he calls
me but he asks how you're doing what
type of people you're hanging out with
what you're paying for [ __ ] rent like
to make sure that you're not you know
spending [ __ ] 10 grand some penthouse
in New York City being an [ __ ] and he
wants to know all this stuff about you
and he told me not to tell you and I
think that's the opposite of a lot of
like this [ __ ] of like we love each
other and you know they were never like
you know like you see now Instagram and
the [ __ ] of like we're so close and
we're so that all right P John
Witherspoon and that's the thing is like
there would be [ __ ] some people from
there there was a thing that you felt on
the show or it's like you know why there
the reason is nobody's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
on set nobody's an [ __ ] on this show
because if you are David can't
you David could end it all you want to
come in and act like you're a [ __ ]
big shot cuz you you you won some
[ __ ] award last year or you or people
are telling you you're a but your
character is the best your character is
the best and you want to come in and
request some kind of [ __ ] trailer or
that it's like somebody will put [ __ ]
two bullets in your head in the in this
[ __ ] show and you're not on the show
anymore so nobody ever if anything we'd
all be in [ __ ] one person's camper
you know sitting around laughing it
there was no and I think a lot of that
was also Jim Jim Jim never let if
anybody's gonna be asking for [ __ ] it's
him and he never did he never said hey I
want there's a this thing so everybody
kind of you know you follow you follow
the vibe on the show example yes sir
sure well I'll tell you somebody I
always knew Edie was a good actress but
when she became when I saw her as a
dangerous act action actress was when
Jim got shot at scene when she's crying
hallway she takes you there she's
unbelievable [ __ ] took me there she
took me there like am i right I know
it's like when a Sean Penn when he finds
out his daughter's dead that movie was
that mr. Gregory yeah yeah yeah the
noise he makes that's somebody lost
somebody that's a tough recreation noise
to make you know Edie had her moments I
think I could say this was my miss
Charles Bronson I'm gonna picture look
at him the second guy I miss is James
Gandolfini never met I never met him but
I can tell you that I miss him on TV
that movie made an Hardy towards the end
okay the game was a game something yeah
I remember seeing him there and going
how much do I [ __ ] miss him from The
Sopranos wait The Sopranos gonna still
kept going I like taking that it would
have lost no fans yeah you know you were
one of the greatest TV shows of all time
I mean not Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] friends a
[ __ ] I'm talking about a show that
changed the fabric of society you know
Ricky and [ __ ]
desi types whatever does he lose yeah
yeah yeah yeah I didn't have HBO growing
up I remember the night that the finale
aired I literally heard I was living in
ball what year did the failure ten years
after so I guess 1990 2009 yeah I was
living in Boston and I knew my friends
were watching and I heard people when I
went black heard people and then i'm
facebook and other oceans and the one
thing I wanted to ask you was because it
happens a lot but like you went from a
kid and then towards the end of the show
because I watched it later you weren't
like you you your character was not the
most liked character at all yeah what is
that like people like start hating you
or do people have a bad weird reaction
to you when you were like not as much
like a OD not that little kid anymore
like you know what's funny I feel like
that's more like an online culture thing
where people are like [ __ ] you you suck
like walking around New York City nobody
ever [ __ ] says that [ __ ] you know
nobody people are just happy to see you
and they want to tell you they love the
show and and this so like I mean there
were there were definitely people who
would tell me like man I [ __ ] hate
your character and I'm like N and
especially people who would meet me like
hanging out and party and they'd be like
man I hate your character but you're
[ __ ] nothing like that you know piece
of [ __ ] or that little [ __ ] nerd or
whatever but I remember like doing
interviews and saying I get it because I
see it like I want to smack him in the
face sometimes like I want to [ __ ]
grab a vehicle what do you you know like
you felt but that's the that's the whole
[ __ ] point of you know that's what
people want to that's a [ __ ] that you
know that Tony sees himself that he
[ __ ] hates about himself you know
that [ __ ] had some great scenes
around the same when she gets Hamid and
he brings her back and you're like oh I
go upstairs AJ no I she's doing ecstasy
but I gotta go upstairs yeah when you
put the [ __ ] thing under the crew
your arm when you we're gonna go to the
military academy and you're all oh you
sold it
Robert you sold me you're like you had
this look on your face like you wanna
[ __ ] shoot yourself yeah and you sold
it there was so many scenes when you
went after you know Carano and you want
to have to have watch outside yeah that
was a [ __ ] tremendous scene with you
and Jim what he told you by you know you
always say you're a hypocrite [ __ ]
Michael you know what's funny it's crazy
that you brought that up that's the only
scene I ever felt I did good
that is a beautiful scene that's the
only scene I ever [ __ ] not only that was
that was like yeah you know you were
seasoned by then and you were used to
him but that was a beautiful scene that
was a real father and son scene but you
had all when you're changing the flat
that's a [ __ ] great scene I don't
know that he goes AJ you loved your
uncle Jackie or some [ __ ] and then he
goes what do you know about me and
you're like hesitant you're like up I
don't know whatever the kids say it was
good I don't remember that alone he's
changing the flag he's I trying to sweat
off and you're just a little kid and he
goes AJ what do you know about me and
like I don't know it's his uncle
Jackie's stole money from the union's
son Jackie loved you like all those
scenes you told Robert you so thank you
that all the crack ho oh that's a crack
ho right right you could the black baby
yeah that all those scenes you know even
Jamie Lynn yeah Jamie's [ __ ] great
when they went up to boot and he [ __ ]
chokes the guy and he's talking to her
in the car and he's like you know what I
do that it was a if you've noticed I'm
surprised that they even did the
Irishman because I haven't seen it yet
you saw it no not yet because three and
a half hours I know three hours yes
that's good it's good for your [ __ ]
yeah but it was such a show that
coverage so many like the mob world
could never recover again the Mafia
genre
movies never really took off again ten
years well it's hard to when we had ten
years to develop a character it's hard
to then have to do it in [ __ ] two
hours you know when you're [ __ ] when
you when you've been watching a show for
[ __ ] five years and then that's six
seasons coming on and you got everybody
in the [ __ ] living room and the
static from the HBO comes it's hard to
recreate that because how do you get
people excited to walk it to turn on the
[ __ ] TV you know now everybody's so
[ __ ] everybody's a critic thumbs up
thumbs down I like that I don't like
that
there was no if you'd like to show get
the [ __ ] out of the room that's how
Sopranos was it was we're gonna watch
the problems if you don't like it get
the [ __ ] out there wasn't no you know oh
I don't giving it [ __ ] for tomatoes
or whatever people are [ __ ] yeah it's
like people were chatting every and that
was the thing it's like I I think a lot
of people in Jersey just [ __ ] loved
it for what at what you know there's
this book I was [ __ ] reading about the
mastery of love and it talks about I'm
reading a lot of these books now cuz I'm
all [ __ ] you know I'm trying to get my
life together and be a [ __ ] adult and
care about people and the what it says
is like you know it's like let's say you
say like I Love New York well when you
think about New York you love it and
that's it you don't try and [ __ ]
change it you know we're with people you
go yeah I like that person but they
[ __ ] you know they do this I don't
like that it's like you just have to
[ __ ] accept it I think that's what
people in [ __ ] Jersey did they were
just you could you could they they
didn't go oh well I like it but you know
he wouldn't wear wear his hat like that
it was just we are [ __ ] we love this
show we're all in they never came up
with the like I feel like now these
[ __ ] movies are made and every
[ __ ] person on the Internet is like
you in that third SIA they shouldn't
have ended it that way or that I mean
obviously people hated to some people
hated the ending of Sopranos but besides
that I never heard anybody called to me
and try and [ __ ] critique it or say
you know how come why didn't why didn't
they do it this way or that people just
I love the show you know that's what
people would say two of the shows that
spawned The Sopranos were Breaking Bad
obviously and Sons of Anarchy yeah
there's a threat that somebody sent me
one time about
Aniki because Jack's tell away sneakers
right he was white sneakers bikers
[ __ ] Hey well somebody came up to
James Gandolfini uh who was a legit
[ __ ] mutt like we'd meet these guys
all the time who come up to you and go
hey hey you know what you do on that
show that's what I do in real life
maybe so you're you've made it to
[ __ ] 40 by going around tell telling
people you don't know that like us like
you're just [ __ ] really you know so
you meet a lot of people who pretend to
[ __ ] do whatever but Jim met one guy
who was legit and he didn't he didn't
say any I'm doing it he came over when
he goes hey he goes uh
wise guy he goes it wouldn't never wear
shorts don't do that don't don't worry
the shorts and then I remember Jim went
I think Jim went to David and told him
he's like I know I know I felt what this
guy was saying tell you then carmine
lupertazzi went James Tony on the Shelf
and he goes I heard that John one up the
house where barbecue last week it was
yeah why he was a boss never was sure I
said right James like what the [ __ ] is
he saying yeah cuz David David would
take [ __ ] you know like I David's a
[ __ ] genius he doesn't need me to do
anything but there were times in your
life where you'd show up and I'm [ __ ]
I you know there was a time where I was
crazy about like Slayer and Pantera and
just [ __ ] smoking weed and listen to
heavy metal and going to concerts and
then the next episode I was [ __ ]
skateboard and listening to [ __ ]
Pantera and this and it was like you
know so he would he would take [ __ ] from
his own life but also from [ __ ]
hanging out with it like there were
there was [ __ ] that he took from Tony
Sirico that taught like if you watch
Tony Sirico for [ __ ] three days
you're coming up with that you know like
we would go away on a trip for 23 go for
three days and your does if he would
come up to us on red carpets and he
would have a travel bottle of obsession
he always smelled like obsession and he
would pour it in his hand and then smack
you like on the face on both side and
you would just [ __ ] really wreak the
entire night for air and people you know
you're meeting celebrities and they're
coming to give you a hug or a Ken
they're like cheese this [ __ ] guy he
smells like a [ __ ] bottle of cologne
and then actresses would also come up to
us and tell us he hugged me and I
smelled like him for the rest of the
you know cuz he and there was so much
[ __ ] that he like I remember one time we
were doing a like I think the DVDs are
coming out and like The Wiz wanted us to
sign DVDs so the first couple of people
come up and the guys talking to me you
know how are you how's the show ladies
talk to me for like five minutes or
whatever and there's a line of [ __ ]
hundreds of people but I'm not gonna
tell this guy like hey you can't talk we
gotta do all these people so I just sit
there and I answer his questions or
whatever and he walks away and Tony
Sirico [ __ ] puts his hand up to the
guy who's sending people our way he puts
his hand up and he looks and he goes
Robert sign them and send them because
that's it and he would do [ __ ] he had
these one-liners all the time that if
you just stayed around him enough the
[ __ ] that he would say and I know
there's there's gotta be
I didn't watch the show so I don't know
what Paulie walnuts says in the show but
I guarantee you there's a percentage of
that [ __ ] that just when David would be
around Tony Sirico because you hear him
say stuff and it was [ __ ] hilarious
he was so he was unbelievable he qicang
he came to my [ __ ] confirmation in
real life in the [ __ ] what is that
three-breasted [ __ ] double breasted
Bobby what the [ __ ] yeah the hook the
hair [ __ ] slicked back with an
envelope full of money like there was no
it was it was crazy man we were and
people people who were my family wrapped
my confirmation and they're like that's
you know that's Paulie walnuts you know
nobody's going oh my god there's [ __ ]
200 they're like there's [ __ ] Paulie
walnuts and then you had people who were
the opposite of who they were on the
show like [ __ ] Edie you know you meet
Edie somewhere and she's just like super
just nice woman with her dog and she's
like really friendly and understanding
really friendly yeah just so like sweet
and this and then she'd go into the hair
and makeup camper and come out to
whatever hours later with the [ __ ]
long nails and the big hair and the like
a Armani [ __ ] matching outfit with
the gold chains and you're like holy
[ __ ] that's the odd like Tony Sirico
wouldn't let people do his hair he came
with his own [ __ ] done he wouldn't say
he's he would sitting out here makeup
Charlotte or someone knew he'd be like
there's a rule in this place you don't
touch this and point at his hair he's
like you don't [ __ ] touch my hair
yeah it was it was crazy it wasn't like
like you said it was like if I don't
know what my life would have been like
now if if I did got some [ __ ] like
Disney show when I was 11 and fun I
don't know yeah cuz people people meet
me and Jamie sometimes together and
they're like God what was it like it
must have been so crazy then it's like
the cool part was was we lived our life
because no [ __ ] 15-year old know what
Sopranos was I could go [ __ ] and walk
around and hang out people my age all
day nobody would say a [ __ ] word and
what he said anything and then as soon
as we'd be we'd go to a [ __ ] store
and then somebody would be like hey
aren't you you're over there on the
[ __ ] cover of the [ __ ] TV Guide
and you're just like in you know yeah
but let's let's go back to the [ __ ]
we [ __ ] parking I still sometimes I
still can't you know that I'm like we
got paid to be on what people say is the
[ __ ] best show at there's times where
I still I wake up in the morning and I'm
like I just think about how [ __ ]
grateful I am for it and how you know I
told you when we spoke on the phone last
night I no doubt in my mind David Chase
saved my life there's no doubt in my
mind cuz I know the first time I took a
[ __ ] percocet what it felt like and
if if I didn't have when I quit doing
[ __ ] drugs and all that [ __ ] if I
didn't have this on the other side if I
didn't have like I [ __ ] just moved
out to LA started a podcast I got a
[ __ ] apartment I did all this stuff
because sir promised you know it's like
oh all this freedom that I have and this
kind of thing where it's like if I
didn't have that if I had my [ __ ]
grandfather's job I don't I don't know
it wouldn't I don't think it'd be good I
could be wrong but I just I know you
know there's times where you're [ __ ]
taken fifteen percocets a day and
somebody [ __ ] who's giving you those
percocets goes you know heroin is
[ __ ] a lot cheaper and it's not a bit
but I would go do it well I got checks
coming in you know I'll stick with the
[ __ ] percocet thanks where who knows
what would happen if [ __ ] you know
some some when I if I was [ __ ] 18 and
had my grandfather's job or [ __ ]
whatever it dropped out of school and
[ __ ] hate in my life and somebody
said hey you know heroines [ __ ]
cheaper I might have been like yeah well
I only got [ __ ] ten bucks on me so I
guess that's what we're doing tonight
and I might not I have no idea but I
just
what's they with a part case it's called
pajama pants it's you and Jamie me Jamie
linen our friend cast
and I just want it to be like that I
want to be [ __ ] you talk about in
[ __ ] pajama panama's and [ __ ]
sitting around and laughing and telling
old stories make it new stories and just
uh we're about 10 episodes in and I'm
I'm so [ __ ] happy to be doing it
because it's like I found in later years
with me and Jamie we always kept in
touch but every time we would see each
other it would be catching up you know
and then by the time you're done [ __ ]
catching up with somebody and then you
leave and then you see them a month or
three months later that you're catching
up again so it's so nice to see
guaranteed to see like I went to her
house last Sunday to watch football and
like we're hanging out and stuff but to
guarantee every week I know I'm gonna
see her for an hour or however long we
[ __ ] talk for and [ __ ] and we
could really get back into each other's
lives like I was living in New York that
I moved to Vegas and she was always out
here and she's got her kids and
everything and like we're like a family
you know she's like a sister to me and
her not being in my life I felt like
something was missing it's great to have
her back in and it's it's also great to
be telling her these kind of stories cuz
there's a lot of them that she doesn't
know because she's so innocent and so
[ __ ] amazing and sweet and pure that
I would never tell her like back in the
day like yeah I'm on [ __ ] day three
of [ __ ] doing blow in someplace with
[ __ ] garbage bags on the windows and
I owe you know we haven't landed and I
would just say to her like yeah you know
I've been partying a little you know
like nothing I didn't want I didn't want
her to feel bad I didn't want to put
anything in her head so now when I sit
and we have microphones and I [ __ ]
tell these stories and we get her real
reactions for the first time and we're
just it's there's a little bit of
therapy in it there's [ __ ] great
catching up there's we just laugh in
it's it's everything it's get and then
it's like we had like drea de Matteo on
so it's like getting to catch up with
her and talk about the [ __ ] soprano
stories and this but then just you know
there's some episodes where we go thirty
minutes without mentioned soprano so
it's just it's all I love it I'm so
happy I moved here and I hope I hope
this is like the next chapter in my life
you know I hope that's that's the oh you
say like who are you now I hope it's a
healthy guy who's moving in the right
direction and has a [ __ ] podcast
that's uh you know that steadily keeping
me keeping me going because like I said
to you it's people tell you you got you
got to do something
creative you know do something creative
and you're living in New York and you're
like every what walking down the street
go into the deli ordering a coffee then
going to meet my friend and [ __ ]
Washington Square Park and then you walk
in here and then go and take in a
[ __ ] boxing class now I don't feel
anything [ __ ] missing and then I
lived in Vegas for two years and I felt
like my [ __ ] sub all of my organs
were out of my [ __ ] butt like I was
like I just felt like I was again maybe
that piece of [ __ ] lint floating in
the air like I was just like man there's
and I would meet people at the poker
table who never didn't know Sopranos
anything and they would just hear me
[ __ ] talk to somebody in vehicle man
you should suck and write a book or you
know you should just so like it pushed
me back into thinking like yeah I do
have to do something creative because it
also gives me there there is a part of
my life that I feel like is missing when
I'm when I'm not doing it you know and
you go and and Vegas was just you know I
took up gambling for a long time and the
last 10 years basically all I've been
doing is playing poker and I [ __ ]
loved it and I just I hit a wall I got
to the point where I was like I can't go
sit at a table with eight strangers
every day anymore like I now that I'm so
like I used to just take percocets and
you could [ __ ] I sit anywhere you
know I could sit on the [ __ ] tunnel
Mac in a plane for six hours and people
would be a couple we gotta get off this
plane and I'd be like why you know we're
[ __ ] to be the same as I'm sitting my
lip but well now that I'm sober and when
I'm sitting on that [ __ ] at that
table with eight strangers and they're
talking about stupid [ __ ] that makes me
want to [ __ ] flip the table over and
you and by the way one day it's fine but
when it's your life and you're going
alright it's [ __ ] Monday it's time to
go play poker and you're like oh my god
I got to go sit with these guys for
[ __ ] eight hours and it's just
torture and I stopped enjoying the game
I stopped study like I was always
studying poker and I was part of these
like poker academies and I was really
[ __ ] into it I love doing it and I
was making money in this and I just saw
it all
following away cuz I couldn't I couldn't
handle being around these people every
day and it's like why I don't wanna do a
TV show because it's unknown you know
I'm going to sit at a table with a
people I don't know what the [ __ ]
they're gonna be talking about some
people are [ __ ] it's just you you you
hearing the same stories over and over
and the same kind of pin they're talking
about their night last night in Vegas
and I just hit a wall you know so I
called up Jamie and I called my
from Cassim and hopefully this is this
is the next chapter in my life well man
you got an open [ __ ] door here and
they tell me why come up and talk [ __ ]
your family it you're the first person
to have me on their podcast since I got
on the walk I really appreciate you
having my coffee girl for you thank you
you know love that you know if you want
to stop by The Improv tomorrow say hello
to Joe for sure how we'd love to shake
you that's awesome yeah you want to do
what yeah man I'm a big fan thank you
that you got your life together listen
to you on the best show of all [ __ ]
time
you made your marketing you're like Tony
Montana make your marking you're forced
yes let me read so bad do not forget
thanks again man Miami's sold out but
Town Hall December 6th they added a
second show and I still got
[ __ ] tickets real quick let me
ask you something we're in the middle of
football season all right
you like winning money you like betting
sports I'll tell you where I put my
money down you ready my bookie Dodd AG
if you try to bet on the NFL MMA um see
Chinese ping-pong whatever the buck my
bookies got it they got the better
incentives and more lines than any other
sports book period I've told you once
I'll tell you again this year they're
running a super contest run allowance to
enter you pick five teams a week against
the spread you rack up the points first
place is guaranteed a hundred thousand
[ __ ] dollars all right they just
revamped the site and it's looking
[ __ ] tip-top module so go take a look
if you haven't already and listen it's
Tuesday cut the [ __ ] we're gonna double
your first deposit right now you like
Joey what's that if you put in a nickel
we give you a nickel use promo code
Church CH you are CH they got a hundred
percent bonus on your initial deposit up
to $1,000 so go to my bookie dot AG
today [ __ ] that's my bookie my bo o
ki e dot AG and use promo code Church my
bookie you play you win you get paid
listen if you're still wearing those
[ __ ] sock
from Kmart and you knows other dumpy
[ __ ] places with holes you're making
a big [ __ ] mistake all right
Stan's socks are here to rock your
[ __ ] Christmas incredible design and
comfort unique styles you can't get
anywhere else and if you want to show a
little love to yourself or the people in
your life
give them the stance now when you show a
little ankle you're also showing off
what makes you special whatever you're
into they collaborate with the best of
them
star wars socks harley davidson socks
they even got Grateful Dead [ __ ]
socks and they clean they're not like
[ __ ] dirty Grateful Dead sucks just
designs so every football baseball
basketball team you got that on there -
Stan's socks are incredibly comfortable
I got him on my feet I'm on my feet a
lot and like I told you in the beginning
when I fly I put these [ __ ] on
I got the icon socks for myself and for
my wife I got her some cute little ankle
socks that she likes and even I even got
to fly and do some nice blue socks that
say good vibes just to remind them of
what's important in life [ __ ]
so do me a favor Stan's makes a great
gift right now for the church family
Stan's has a great offer go to Stan's
comm slash Church and they're gonna
throw on a feat of free pair of socks
with any purchase trust me you're gonna
love these [ __ ] sucks they're nice
and comfortable tremendous like I said I
use them when I fly when I gotta walk
around airports and it just is a makes
my feet feel [ __ ] tremendous that's
Stan's calm sta NCE dot-coms last Church
to get your free pair of socks because
if they're not Stan's they're not sucks
I want to thank Stan's I want to thank
my bookie I wanna thank my main man
Robert Isla or I think the [ __ ]
but most importantly I want to thank you
[ __ ] for always having my back
and the whole thing do not forget
December 6 10:30 tickets still available
and that's it that's that I want to
thank you again brother your energy I
think I want to thank you again my
little savage and like I said most
importantly you [ __ ] at the
house see you Thursday morning tip-top
Magoo stay black kick that [ __ ] meal
way